this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespaces the all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit
the history of madagascar is rich in
stories of conquest piracy colonial
struggle and charismatic monarchs
amongst one of the best known characters
of this epic is queen ranavalona the
first who ruled the powerful marina
kingdom from 1828 to 1861. a quick look
into her past will reveal how she
protected the independence of her
islands from the influence of colonial
powers but it will also highlight the
ruthlessness of her actions believed to
have caused 2.5 million deaths titles
often associated were there include the
mad queen the female caligula or the
bloody mary of madagascar it must be
said that most of what we know about
ranavalona we know it through her
enemies so a healthy pinch of salt
is definitely advised nonetheless in
today's episode we're going to do our
best to learn about the multiple facets
of this ruler what he became famous
thanks to dramatic acts of bloodshed but
had a soft spot for bureaucracy and data
processing
[Music]
early accounts of ranavalona's childhood
are scarce and contradictory she may
have been born in 1788 or 1790.
at birth she may have been named remarvo
according to some stories she was a
commoner of humble origins according to
others she may have been the daughter of
prince andrea
that is an extremely long name that i
can't pronounce is cousin what is
certain is that she was born in the
marina kingdom the largest and strongest
of the national entities which composed
madagascar at the time additionally most
accounts agree that her father thwarted
an assassination plot against the prince
oh when prince unpronounceable became
king he rewarded his savior by adopting
remarvo as his own daughter who he then
betrothed to his son prince radamer in a
slightly less incestuous version of the
tale the young girl was adopted by
raleigh soka the king's sister in 1810
radhara descended to the throne aged
only 18 but his young wife remarvo was
not automatically the queen the girl now
known as ranibal owner had to contend
with the prince's affections of another
11 wives she may have been his first
wife but she wasn't at all his favorite
the two never had a close relationship
and ranavalona never bore a royal child
her situation had caught in other words
was rather shaky meanwhile outside of
the royal palace radama was accumulating
successes in 1820 he signed a commercial
treaty with the british empire which
secured military equipment and training
for his growing professional army at the
head of his troops the king expanded the
marina kingdom taking over almost all of
madagascar then he established a
collaboration with the london missionary
society who opened schools spread
literacy and converted many locals to
christianity finally the modernizing
monarch brought an end to the slave
trade a business which had greatly
profited marine aristocracy in the past
this drive for reforms definitely
benefited the military power of the king
but redama was not without opposition
when he modernized the army he ordered
all of his soldiers to keep their hair
short demonstrations erupted led by
traditionalist women who wanted to
reclaim the ancestral right to braid the
long hair of their warrior husbands
rodama would not have any of that he
ordered for the leaders of the revolt to
be brutally slain and their remains to
be fed to wild dogs further opposition
simmered in the shadows
ultra-traditionalist aristocrats who
grumbled against his apertures to
european powers and christian
missionaries this may be why his death
in the summer of 1828 is regarded as
suspicious according to one version the
king had been poisoned by his own wife
ranavalona in cahoots with the
traditionalists more realistically
redama had fallen out with syphilis or
cirrhosis and was suffering so badly
that he cut his own throat rana bellona
now had to make a decision disappear
quietly into the night or fight for
succession
[Music]
the rival heir to the throne was prince
rakhitobi eldest son of redharma's
eldest sister he had been educated in
england and was attuned to the late
king's pro-western policies but
rakhitobe knew that the claim was not
100 safe according to the marina belief
system any child of ranival owner would
have taken precedence even if born after
adam's death and even if realistically
not conceived by redharma according to
some accounts ranavalona was indeed
pregnant at the time and not with
remedy's child she feared the urakitobi
may attempt to assassinate her and knew
that offense was the best defense the
widow occupied the royal palace and
rallied supporters to her cause the
ultra-conservative aristocrats and
officers from her home village all came
to her defense with her back covered
ranavalona declared herself queen of the
marina on august 1 1828 claiming that
this was ramada's wish the following
june 1828 the queen underwent a double
ascension in which she would set the
tone for a reign divided between
modernity and return to ancestral
customs in a public coronation ceremony
she wore a splendid gown fashioned by a
french tailor but in a secret ride she
was anointed with the blood of a freshly
slaughtered bull by the time she
performed both rituals she had
successfully got rid of all claimants to
the throne her nephew rakitobe had been
gored by a spear his mother had been
starved to death most of their relatives
were also executed according to
biographer keith laider thousands of
suspected opposers met a similar fate in
a show of force designed to consolidate
her as the ultimate ruler this she made
clear to her subjects with a coronation
speech never say she is only a feeble
and ignorant woman how can she rule such
a vast empire i will rule here to the
good fortune of my people and the glory
of my name the ocean shall be the
boundary of my realm and i will not see
the thickness of one hair of my realm
all right we'll get back to today's
video in just a minute but first here's
a word from today's video sponsor
squarespace now more than ever people
are getting creative with their time
they're reaching into their savings
account to start a new business or
launch a blog or a website something
like that and the world is yours with
squarespace it's the platform to use
when you're ready to get started on the
next web project that you've been
thinking about you're looking to get in
and out quick without thinking too much
about what your website should look like
bam use one of their quick beautiful
templates to make a website that's fresh
and for you like it's right out of the
box or maybe more of a hands-on person
you got lots of opinions and ideas about
what exactly your site should look like
squarespace gives you all the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical nonsense to worry about once
you're done setting up your website
tinkering with the design if you're so
inclined or maybe playing around with
the colors there are many extra features
that squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member only areas analytics commercial
opportunities and customer support
everything you'd ever want is in one
place so when you're ready to get
started on the next project of yours big
or small if it involves a website you've
got to do it with squarespace right now
you go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
your new site go to squarespace.com
forward slash biographics to save 10 of
your first purchase of a website or a
domain and now let's get back to it
[Music]
some biographies claim that the queen
quickly undid most of radama's reforms
she severed ties with the british and
restored local forms of worship against
christian influence but in reality the
shift was not quite so clear-cut
according to british diplomat and
historian mervin brown during the first
months of her reign ranavalona acted
entirely out of pragmatism this meant
that she oscillated between continuity
with the late king's pro-british
policies and a traditionalist agenda as
she saw more fit and advantageous ways
to consolidate power for example on the
28th of november 1928 the queen
denounced the anglo-marina treaty of
1820 and on the 25th of march 1829 she
expelled the british diplomat agent
robert lyle but at the same time she
entertained a good relationship with the
christian preachers of the london
missionary society or lms they were
allowed to hold mass convert locals
celebrate sacraments and run schools in
exchange a community of expat artisans
attached to the lms made themselves
useful by setting up workshops to
manufacture soap hydraulic machinery and
even gunpowder this last contribution
was particularly well received in
october of 1829. from a capital
antananarivo the queen had to contend
with the double threat a rebellion of
the sacalava people in the west and a
french invasion on the east coast the
french colony in reunion ireland
depended heavily on cheap labor and
supplies imported from madagascar a
steady supply which was interrupted by
the queen in 1829. when the betsy masaka
people revolted in eastern madagascar
french king charl the tenth took the
occasion to punish those pesky marinas
by ordering an attack on the port town
of tos messina and mahavillona the
invaders however were first weakened by
malaria and then met fierce resistance
from the malagasy army in july 1830 a
revolution toppled shall the 10th and
the new monarch louis philippe was less
keen on expensive colonial adventures
eating british pressure the french
withdrew exactly one year later this was
a great victory for the queen an image
and confidence booster but the war had
disrupted trade on the east coast of her
kingdom which relied heavily on the
export of cattle and rice to mauritius
and reunion those goods were sold
against hard foreign currency which
could be reinvested into the purchase of
firearms ammunitions the queen was now
short on income and less cash meant less
musket balls and who could tell if the
french were to return this is when the
monarch developed a talent for
bureaucracy which may not make for
internet headlines but it surely helped
her economy first she developed an
efficient network of civil servants on
the east coast but the stroke of a pen
most of the military officers in the
region were appointed portal authorities
with powers to regulate trade then she
issued precise frequent regular
instructions to these officers relying
on the written word which was a
departure from the practices of marina
kings who used to issue orders orally
during official assemblies the portal
authorities were instructed to attract
new foreign buyers for their cattle and
rice when possible they were to ask
payment either in foreign currency or
directly munitions to stock the royal
garrisons the next step was to regulate
imports ranavalona knew that dependency
on imports for basic goods could leave
her country at the mercy of european
powers therefore she ordered her civil
servants to limit imports to the
strictly necessary and to pay for these
in local currency or by bartering with
local goods as these practices took hold
the queen established a two-way
communication flow she was informed at
all times of all the levels of
production of local goods as well as the
levels of import for the same
commodities this data was centralized
and processed by the queen herself who
was able to impose maximum quotas for
imported merchandise the centralization
of economic policy clearly required a
tight grip if not an iron fist
ranavalona would realize almost
immediately if decentralized officers
took advantage of her physical distance
and issued decrees on their own accords
if a bureaucrat dared to deviate from
her policies he may expect a message
like this one i have the sole authority
to make law through my words if you
attempt to speak in my name your words
will return to me like a bird of great
destruction you will be tried and
punished or this one is even better
though i'm far away i stand
like a sentinel over you and with that i
think we found our new out of office
reply
after the east coast was pacified the
queen's relationship with the lms and
the british community began to sour in
november of 1831 she issued a ban on
sacraments no more malagasy could be
baptized and those who already were
could not take part in the holy
communion then her governor cracked down
on the christian schools boys as young
as 13 were taken away from class and
most of them were enlisted in the army
the lms feared for a complete closure of
their educational programs but the queen
reversed her policies it seems like she
was more interested in beefing up her
infantry rather than damaging the
well-run schools and in the following
years the number of pupils increased
from 2 500 to 4 000. it appears from
then on that the interplay between the
court and the christian faith was to
follow a series of wild mood swings
influenced by the most senior
aristocrats in the traditionalist party
a watershed moment was the case of
reynet zadonava a christian man who had
begun preaching an inspiring message
according to him christ would soon
return to set everybody free and abolish
slavery court officers interrogated him
and his followers and when he stated
that a slave was the equal of the queen
the soldiers didn't like that one bit
the preacher and his followers were
placed head down in a pit and killed by
pouring boiling water over them the
ultra traditionalist party continued to
feed the queen similar stories of our
christians undermined her authority and
scorned the traditional marine religion
wanaka mentions that on hearing these
stories the queen was so grieved that
she vowed death to all christians on the
26th of february 1835 she sent a message
to the missionaries malagasy could and
would not take part any longer in any
form of christian worship but
missionaries and their friends could
stay if they had any useful knowledge or
craft to impart then on the 1st of march
the queen issued a proclamation ordering
strict deterrence to ancestral customs
all malagasy who were baptized who had
been praying to the christian god or who
simply knew how to read had to come
forward and recant their faith around
this time the queen had realized that a
french invasion was no longer a threat
moreover she had welcomed to court a
useful ally a shipwrecked french
engineer called jean-labord another
rumored lover the advisor had a broad
grasp of mythology and munitions with
the queen's backing he directed the
construction of mantasso a factory town
on the forefront of an ambitious program
of industrialization with madagascar
heading to self-reliance the queen could
finally do without the missionary's
support and could fulfill the
anti-christian policies favored by her
supporters another factor which may have
caused the change in direction was a
shift in the balance of power behind the
scenes in the first two years of her
reign the queen was heavily influenced
by her young prime minister and lover
andream heyer who by the way may or may
not have been the father of the queen's
son rakoto the prime minister was a
supporter of king radamus's previous
policies and therefore friendly to the
missionaries and open to british
influence but andrea m heyer had
powerful enemies an extremely
conservative faction headed by three
brothers of the anda farvaratra family
two of them were also rumored to be
lovers of the queen so it may have been
the result of a power struggle or plain
jealousy that this faction conspired to
eliminate angean hire when the minister
was accused of betraying the queen with
another woman he was forced to undergo
the trial of tangina but he preferred to
have his throat pierced by a spear
we should now clarify what tangina was
this was one of the many brutal
practices instituted by rana malone and
or her supporters as she tightened her
grip against ascension basically if
someone was suspected of opposing the
queen they were forced to take a poison
extracted from the tangena nut which
induces vomiting then they had to
swallow three pieces of chicken skin if
they vomited up all three pieces of skin
they were considered innocent but if
they died from the poison well that was
taken as proof of guilt and if they
survived but did not threat the skins
they were also considered guilty and
they were executed according to
historian gwyn campbell this form of
trial claimed a hundred thousand lives
in 1838 alone another brutal custom
imposed by the ruler was torture by
progressive amputation a brutal fate
imposed especially on non-ethnic
mariners who also regularly suffered
from pillaging and abuse from the army
the most common form of mistreatment was
the traditional practice of fana pawana
forced labour for those subjects who
could not afford their taxes the poorest
among the malagas who were pressed into
service as builders foot soldiers or
litter carriers for the aristocracy
ravanalona had effectively reinstated
slavery causing thousands of deaths due
to starvation exhaustion and disease
christians were of course also a common
target for elaborate punishment in 1836
the army apprehended 14 malagasy
christian leaders who had resisted
orders to give up their religion rad
abalone ordered them to be dangled by
ropes over a rocky ravine the ropes were
then cut and the martyrs plummeted to
their deaths as he is progressed the
queen further descended into a downward
spiral of morbid grotesque holly the
buffalo hunt of 1845 is often cited as
an example on that occasion ranavalona
ordered her entourage to take part in a
large buffalo hunt dragging along
thousands of slaves and servants the
whole party numbered some 50 000 people
who built roads burnt wood and leveled
villages to make way for the queen and
her aristocratic friends as the
expedition marched on searching in vain
for elusive buffalo starvation and
malaria took their toll according to
keith ladler in total 10 000 men women
and children are said to have perished
during the sixteen weeks of the queen's
hunt in all this time there is no record
of a single buffalo being shot
[Music]
around the same time rana bolona had
firmly decided that her island should be
rid of all foreigners on the 13th of may
1845 she passed a new law ordering that
all foreigners should perform unpaid
labor in the execution of public works
the expat community understandably
refused the order and they were
therefore ordered to leave madagascar
within 11 days british traders in tamida
on the east coast sent a letter to the
governor of the british colony on the
island of mauritius venting their
grievances captain kelly of hms conway
was sent to investigate alongside two
french vessels the bear saw and the
zolay the french decided to launch a
punitive expedition
and kelly was game the combined
anglo-french force attacked the fort of
tamadave on the 15th of june reassured
by the flimsy looking defenses when they
realized that the weak palisades were
just a decoy it was too late the
well-trained marine army had concealed
their real barricades behind a decoy
fort and launched a counter-attack the
british and french marines suffered 21
dead and 53 wounded and hastily fled
back to their ships at the end of the
day 21 skulls of the dead marines were
impaled on spikes warning europeans
against further invasions the queen may
have imposed a regime of terror but so
far she'd succeeded in protecting her
realm from colonial rule all while
radovalona's son prince rokoto had grown
into a well-respected young man who
distanced himself from his mother's
policies he did not approve of summary
justice execution by chicken skin or
disguised slavery he became popular
among the malagasy as he released
prisoners and donated food to foot
soldiers in the early 1850s rokoto had
become good friends with a french
businessman jose francois lambert who
had become affluent in mauritius thanks
to the slave trade lampara had been
invited to court after an incident in
which he had saved with his ships and
marina soldiers surrounded by rebelling
farmers lambie had become very wary of
the queen's brutal policies in 1854 he
and drakota began plotting a coup to
overthrow ravallona on the 28th of june
1855 the two conspirators signed a
secret agreement the frenchman committed
to garnering support to their cause in
europe in exchange he would get the sole
right to exploit all minerals forests
and vacant estates in madagascar rocoto
agreed to receive only ten percent of
the profits the next step was to invite
foreign intervention amber wrote to
french emperor napoleon iii inviting him
to invade and establish a protectorate
in later years the junior bonaparte
would be eager to stick his fingers in
countless colonial pies but at that time
he was influenced by the sassamore
school of foreign policy which stressed
indirect rule and catholic missionary
activity over military intervention
undeterred lambert embarked for a tour
of europe seeking to obtain political
and military support to defeat rana
bolona and her army but in 1857 he
returned to the island empty-handed as a
last resort ricotta and lambert enlisted
help from the queen's advisor and
possible lover the shipwrecked engineer
labored they finally decided to set the
coup in motion but it was a total
disaster the queen always kept well
informed by her network of spies she
knew all along what was coming but toyed
with the conspirators giving them a
false sense of security at the last
moment she struck arresting all the
participants except for lambert who
escaped alive rikoto and lambord were
spared but everybody else was sent on a
forced march across swampy islands and
most died from malaria
once again queen ranavalona the first
triumphed unscathed and she would remain
untouchable until the 16th of august
1861. this is when to the frustration of
her enemies the sovereign died
peacefully in her sleep at a funeral a
barrel of gunpowder went off
accidentally killing several mourners a
fittingly violent end to a violent reign
the queen was succeeded by rocoto who
took the style of radhama ii his rule
was short-lived as he was assassinated
only two years later madagascar entered
a period of steady decline marked by
increasingly weaker rulers a period
which ended with a successful french
colonial invasion in 1896. today
ravenolona's legacy is divided and
divisive even in madagascar a tenure in
power is remembered by some as the
darkest period in the island's history
or by others as an age of prosperity
solid economic policies and effective
resistance against foreign invaders it
doesn't help that many of the stories
which concern the queen may or may not
be true if you pale from that beautiful
country please let us know in the
comments your thoughts about today's
protagonist was she a parmad tyrant or a
model of self-determination against the
excesses of colonialism and just before
we leave today right at the beginning of
today's video we said some people have
compared it to bloody mary the blood
contest we've got a video all about her
elizabeth bathory which i will link to
on the screen now and i'll see you next
time now just before you leave today
maybe looking for something else to
watch why not check out my new channel
called wara graphics want to know all of
the details about some of history's most
famous battles and wars come join me on
war of graphics from sherman's march to
the sea to operation barbarossa it's got
people fighting each other or
occasionally animals we will cover it
there is a link below